I am Dakota the bearded lady
for me it's not really like about a
prize it's just about like getting out
there and just being like hey I'm gonna
check who has a beard like what up
every day I would shave it even though I
had razor work because I was just too
ashamed of letting people see like palm
trees they'll be able to see the scars
on my face I know that people are always
looking and I get it you know it's not
every day you see a woman with a beard
but I just try to get through it and
people say something I try to educate
them
this Dakota
I think it's really nothing to be
ashamed of women can grow facial hair
and it's not that big of a deal
I went up there and I it was based on a
flaws I would have wanted I didn't make
it but next time yeah